treatments for obesity medications and
bariatric surgical procedures you may be
put on weight loss medication for
obesity if your BMI is thirty or more or
if your BMI is twenty seven or more and
you also have an obesity related health
problem such as diabetes or high blood
pressure some weight loss medications
prevent your body from taking in fat
from the food you eat other weight loss
medications work by making you feel less
hungry
your healthcare provider may advise a
bariatric surgical procedure if your BMI
is 40 or more or if your BMI is 35 or
more and you also have obesity related
health problems
during a sleeve gastrectomy procedure
your surgeon will remove most of your
stomach this leaves a smaller sleeve
like tube about the size of a banana
called
a gastric sleeve the smaller gastric
sleeve holds less food and makes you
feel full more quickly
during an adjustable gastric band
procedure your surgeon will place a band
around the top of your stomach this
makes a smaller pouch to hold food as a
result you will feel full when eating
smaller portions of food
in another surgical procedure called a
roux-en-y gastric bypass your surgeon
will close off the top of your stomach
with staples this will create a small
pouch then a section of your small
intestine will be attached to the small
stomach pouch this new connection
bypasses most of your stomach as well as
the part of your small intestine where
most of the nutrients from the food you
eat are absorbed as a result you will
eat less food and your body won't absorb
as much of it after a bariatric
procedure it's important to follow the
dietary guidelines from your healthcare
provider and to stay physically active
if you have any questions about
medications or surgical procedures for
obesity talk to your healthcare provider